vous avez l'impression que vous avez
attendu longtemps votre votre chance au
cinéma vous ai commencé par le théâtre
aussi vous avez une blanche je continue
dans le par l'auteur oui ça reste nous
sommes très amis que je viens et
d'halluin m je ne changerai pas de
position à dire non c'est une folle pour
vous le cinéma c'est une activité
intéressante certes mais qui pas
essentiel ah non je ne me juge pas l'une
par rapport à l'autre mais je dis que
pour moi dans ma ville théâtre tient une
place dans la première
pourquoi on vous confie depuis quelques
années des rôles de magistrats de juge
d'instruction vous avez la tête de
l'emploi vous croyez à cette dignité
je ne sais pas la première fois vous
êtes juge d'instruction non non j'ai oui
j'ai endossé quelques contres l'avait
souvent avec gilles sympathique non
c'est entre nous on n'a aucune idée
folle de l'image que l'on peut donner
que représente en fait c'est le metteur
en scène qui dans l'univers qui est
choisie où on participe de sa mythologie
personnelle avec savoir
[Musique]